. Here is maybe the funniest of all of these
moments. Ben Carson, Trump's former secretary
of HUD and former presidential candidate, former
neurosurgeon. I think he went so long at CPAC that
they started playing music. You know how at the
Oscars you go up and after 30 seconds of thanking
people, they start playing music to try to get
you off. Ben Carson wouldn't stop talking. And
they played music and the music repeated it was
like 30 seconds of music. They never they didn't
think we'll need to go longer than 30 seconds of
music with anybody. But Ben Carson kept talking
and talking and talking. And they just kept
playing the music over and over again. And he
seemed completely unaware of what's going on
When they go to Newsmax, even the people on
Newsmax seem to feel bad for him. Check this out.
Speaker 3: They college students, young staffers,
what you need to know about the government
so that you don't have to so that you can hit
the ground running because we of these.
Speaker 1: People, he's in the middle
of his speech and they're playing him off.
Speaker 3: Because 90% of the country, the career
employees, are people who live in this area, who
have the politics of this area and slow things
down to push things forward. We've got to be able
to do much better than that by understanding this
process. So that's what the EPA is all about.
Speaker 1: So now the crowd is trying to help
them by clapping and sort of like, okay,
let's rap. But he just keeps going and.
Speaker 3: This will help us to
determine and answer the question,
which Benjamin Franklin said, if we can keep it.
Speaker 1: When he starts going into quotes,
you know, he's not ending.
Speaker 3: It's a wonderful
system we have. Don't let anybody tell you
anything that's different from that. But
we're the ones who are going to have to do it.
Speaker 1: Did you notice the music stopped
and now they're cycling it again? They're like,
We got to get him off. And he just keeps going.
Speaker 3: And if you want to know, can we keep
it? Find a World War Two veteran and ask them what
was going through their head and day when they on
the shores of Normandy. And all of those people
were being shot and they stepped over those dead
bodies, knowing in many cases they would never
see their loved ones or their homeland again.
Why did they do it? They did it for you.
Speaker 1: The music is still going.
Oh, this guy is unbelievable. Oh, and I just lost
it. Where did that go? Oh, my goodness. That was
crazy. Where did that speech go? We got to get it
back. Eventually, he walks away. That was crazy.
The. The speech just went away. You've got to
see the end, because even the Newsmax hosts seem
to be recognizing what's going on here. It is.
Speaker 3: Okay. It's for that we can live in
peace and safety. Ask them if we can keep it.
Unidentified: We can with all the guys. Thank
you so much. Guys are there, you guys.
Speaker 4: All right, Dr. Ben Carson.
A good speech. A good, solid speech, one that
folks seem to enjoy however it could. It's
not lost on myself or Tom Persily, who joins us
right now, who is the host of America right now
that they were playing the music, I mean,
they're behind. It's not his fault. You.
Speaker 1: No, it's not lost on any of us,
believe me, sir. So there is Ben Carson
bringing his electric personality to CPAC
and it going about as well as we would expect.
Let's now talk about Kimberly GUILFOYLE.